KAMAU BOBB: My
name is Kamau Bobb.
I am the global lead
for diversity, strategy,
and research here at Google.
The discussion today is
about race, and education,
and the future of a
modern technopolis.
In order to get into
that conversation
it's important to understand the
moment that we're currently in.
Obviously the nation here in the
United States and in the world
is in a flux, particularly
the United States
it's relevant to reflect
a little bit on how we got
to the moment that we're in.
We are in a moment of the
conflation of a COVID pandemic
and a social uprising inspired
by the killing of George Floyd.
But in order to get
into race and education,
we do have to pan
back just a bit
and think about the
ideological transition
that the country is in.
However you might feel
about those things,
the reality is that we've
gone through national trauma.
In the beginning, at the
shift of these two ideologies,
there was, if you recall,
the Woman's March.
It was the largest demonstration
in American history,
and it was revealing
a certain kind
of angst about the ideology
that we're currently under.
That was followed
almost immediately
by an immigration debacle that
led to uprisings in airports
all across the country, and
the ban from immigrants coming
from certain Muslim countries.
We were followed that with the
government shutdown, which was,
again, the longest in the
history of the country.
And then there was
the impeachment,
and all the while
there was the angst
dealing with racial discord
and animus, the Charlottesville
demonstration led to a time
where people who are my age,
I was born four years after
Martin Luther King was
assassinated, people
who are my age
having to contend with
words like the Ku Klux Klan
and Nazi affiliated
organizations.
For people, again,
in my generation,
those things are
artifacts of history,
but we had to contend
with them in real time.
And then ultimately, here
we are in this COVID-19
global pandemic and
all of the trauma
that that's put
the country under,
and in the midst of
that, we had to confront
the killing of
George Floyd, which
has sent us all into what I
would call an American sprint.
So discussing race
and education,
and ultimately what a
modern technopolis is,
it would be incomplete
for us to try
to do that without
understanding,
at least contemplating
the effects of the moment
that we're in.
So relative to those two
things, race and education,
the pre-existing conditions
idea is obviously
part of the lexicon
now because we're
talking about a global pandemic
and the disproportionate
impacts that it
has with people who
have pre-existing conditions.
The same is true in
education, and one
of the principal pre-existing
conditions that we're
dealing with in, at least
United States education,
is segregation, racial
segregation specifically.
And again, here too, we have
to be mindful of the fact
that we're not talking about
racial segregation in 1954
previously.
We're talking about it
today, here in 2020.
If you recall, 1954 was Brown
versus Board of Education,
where we decided
as a country that
legalized racial segregation in
schools in America was illegal.
Separate is in fact
inherently unequal.
But here we are today.
I'll use Atlanta where I live
as an example to demonstrate
the degree of racial
segregation that we currently
operate under, and this is by
no means special to Atlanta.
Atlanta happens to be one of the
top two most segregated cities
in the United States, and this
graph crudely, what it shows
is that in the colors that
are dark and gray and black,
that's the predominantly
black section of the city,
and those that are white are
the predominantly white sections
of the city.
And that segregation
is nearly absolute,
and it correlates with
everything, with the quality
of education, with the
quality of public service,
and in this current
moment of social upheaval,
it correlates with
the kind and quality
of interaction with
the police, whether you
get garbage picked up.
It certainly correlates
with the voting patterns
that we see here in the city.
But to make it even more
clear, relative to education,
I think it's important for us
to consider how this actually
plays out, and certainly
for those of us who
live in the United
States and have children,
you know what this is like in
the schools and communities
in which you live.
The names here are immaterial,
but these are basically
the 11 traditional public
high schools in Atlanta,
and all I want to
illustrate here
is that in essentially
eight of those schools,
there are virtually no
white students at all.
And all of the students in the
entire Atlanta Public School
System, essentially
attend three schools.
So it would be in fact true if
we put a sign here that said,
these eight schools
are for blacks only.
And hearkening back
to a previous time,
those kinds of things are
egregious to our sensibilities
here in the middle
of the 21st century.
But this is the reality.
And even in the schools
where white students attend,
those schools
within them are also
segregated such that the white
students have better access
to the advanced placement
courses, to the honors courses,
to the international
baccalaureate courses,
and in this instance, I've
been to all of these schools
personally.
So-- it's not
secondhand information.
I know, in fact, in part because
of my role at Georgia Tech,
I understand how this works.
So this is the street-level
reality of the relationship
between race and education.
Were essentially still living in
two totally bifurcated systems
with two different
sets of expectations
about what education
means, about what education
is offered to one group of
students versus the other,
and clearly that
limits their ability
to participate when they move
into the post-secondary world.
To demonstrate
that even further,
at the Georgia Tech
College of Computing,
I'm using Georgia
Tech as an example
because I'm on the
faculty there as well.
I'm the Senior Director of
the Constellation Center
for Equity and Computing.
So I'm speaking on behalf
here of information
that I know well.
Ultimately what we've
seen over the last decade
and some is that the fraction
of black and Latinx students
who have been admitted into
the College of Computing
has only increased
incrementally,
but for Asian and white
students, as you can see here,
there's been a significant
increase, principally
for Asian students as you can
see that increase is dramatic.
But what that is
an indication of
is the basic infrastructure
that is segregated,
which is the pre-existing
condition that
limits students' opportunity to
be able to play in this higher
level.
And that indicates, of
course, and brings us
to the idea of what a
modern technopolis is,
and in my construction of this
term, when cities like Atlanta,
like Chicago, like
the Bay Area, Oakland,
New York, Raleigh-Durham, and
the Research Triangle Park,
they have built economic
development strategies
that are premised on the
idea that tech companies will
show up in their regions and
drive the economy forward.
And that is a reasonable
expectation, particularly given
the disproportionate
positive impacts to economies
that tech companies have,
but what does that do?
It requires a certain skill set.
So when companies,
not unlike Google,
are planning for where
these locations should be,
they do an assessment
of the workforce
and the workforce's
capabilities in those places.
And in the current,
we're sneaking up
on the end of the first
quarter of the 21st century,
and this is news and
language that we all know,
what are 21st century skills?
What is the promise of
a modern technopolis?
The promise is that
we will have people
who have computational skills,
who have technical skills, who
have the wherewithal to
be able to participate
in this modern
economy in some way,
and that's a range from
people who are software
engineers and advanced
computation lists,
to those who can use basic
analytical and numerical skills
to participate in
whatever industry,
whether it be art, cultural
generation, service industries,
gig-economies, et cetera.
So we have to
agree that there is
some certain level of
numeracy and analytical skills
and technical skills
that make people
able to participate in what
I call a modern technopolis.
So the challenge
here, of course,
is that if we're thinking
about what citizenship means
in that space, and here
I don't mean citizenship
in the litigious sense of who
is legally able to qualify
to be a citizen, but
rather citizenship
in the sense of
mutual responsibility
and the ability to be viable,
to be meaningful, to be present,
and to have a means
of contributing
in this modern technopolis,
in this modern economy.
In order to do that, you have to
have the aforementioned skills.
But because the segregation is
so virulent, and what it does
is it constrains the
opportunity of certain sections
of these cities to be
able to participate.
In the case of Atlanta,
what I was alluding to,
to make this case ultimately,
is that we already
know that black students
in the public school
system in Atlanta,
for example, are
segregated in ways
that lock them out
of their ability to participate
to get the access to higher
Ed. institutions
like Georgia Tech,
like Stanford, like
Carnegie Mellon,
like the current competitive
and selective institutions,
and those of course, are not the
only higher Ed. institutions.
But when companies are planning
where they ought to go,
particularly tech companies,
they use those institutions
as proxy for their availability
of a modern workforce.
So if we already
know our priority
that the system that we
have completely and totally
and structurally locks
out certain sections
of the population,
and at the same time,
we build an economic
development strategy that's
premised on the fact that we
know that those students can't
compete, we're
building a future,
we're building an
idea of citizenship
in a modern technopolis
without them.
So that means the mass
migration out of technopolises,
of technopoli if you like,
without the black population,
the Latinx population, the
poor population in rural
communities, where
those students,
because of the structure
in which they sit
in their educational
enclaves, cannot participate.
And when we plan for and
build an infrastructure
to generate economic development
in a technopolis, knowing that,
we're planning for a
future without them.
We have to be clear
about what that means,
and in an environment
that we're currently in,
which is why I began
this discussion--
in the way that I did, because
we're in a social uprising
here.
We're contending
with what it means
to be an American
citizen, to be viable,
to have equal and human rights,
to have your presence be
acknowledged, be
respected, and cherished,
and if in this specific line
of dealing with technopoli,
we're planning for futures
without certain people,
it conflates this other problem
that we're contending with now.
So as we go forward, our
challenges are clear.
These are things that
all of us are contending
with in the individual
decisions that we're
making with our schools,
with our companies,
with our non-profit
organizations, et cetera.
But access resources
and philosophy.
Access obviously is to
the kind of education
that makes you viable.
The resources is
the infrastructure
that makes those educational
enclaves palatable, functional,
to make sure that
teachers are prepared.
If you recall in
the last two years,
there are about 11 states where
the public school teachers
across the country
were on strike because
of inadequate resources.
And what does that
all aggregate to?
A philosophy.
What is our philosophy about
the utility of education
in a Democratic-Republic?
To make sure that all of the
students have the wherewithal,
there are all in an
integrated part of what
a modern technopolis is.
So I would charge
us, charge myself
with trying to consider
what we do, and I think
where we go from here, because
the country is in such a flux,
our bias is towards
making a quick act to try
to bolster deficits
that we can easily see.
There aren't enough devices.
There aren't enough
students in communities
with broadband connectivity.
All of those things
are important,
but my argument is
in the consideration
of race and education,
what we have to do here
is we have to contend
with our philosophy.
We're asking the public
education infrastructure
in the United
States, which I would
argue is one of the pillars of
our Democratic-Republic, what
is it that we are choosing
to invest in that such
that we don't a priori
decide that there are
certain sets of students who
have essentially no future,
irrespective of
their own abilities,
ambitions, and capabilities,
they don't have
a future in this country
that we're trying to build,
particularly one that is
driven by a technopolis idea.
So those are the charges that
I think that we're up against.
It's a moment for
us all to consider
the very best of the
original American principles
and a global sense of
what it means to be human.
Thank you much.